[Music]
what's going on guys
Mission Impossible fallout opens this
week I had the opportunity to sit down
with the cast including mr. Henry Cavill
check it out the moment where you kind
of cocked your arms right how did that
moment come together
that was just an off-the-cuff idea just
one of the takes I did it it just felt
right and and I went from there and it
stayed in the movie in general what's
your process for getting into character
typically my process involves just
knowing knowing the script as well as I
can and the script is evolving and
moving as it was I just trusted my cue
as much as I possibly could it was speak
to McHugh about where we were is
anything changed he'd always tell me of
anything was changing so it was a
wonderful collaborative process gotcha
is there pressure to top yourselves
every time and how do you guys approach
that that always makes me laugh when
people ask me that because in the UK top
yourself is a euphemism for suicide if
you say oh I'm gonna top myself it means
please don't I'm gonna Rendell
[Music]
how do you go about developing the
physical appearance of a character in
any role that you take on
I think the physicality of a character
is extremely important it wasn't so much
a matter of a you know very lean
six-pack kind of shape like Superman was
because there's no shirtless aspect to
this right but I had to look like I was
the hammer for the CIA
yeah so he didn't have to do as many
sit-ups for this role no no I don't have
too many sit-ups roll the helicopter
sequence it was so crazy and out of
control how dangerous in real life was
that there's Tom's helicopter and
Henry's helicopter and then there's the
camera helicopter and then there's my
helicopter then there's a medevac
helicopter in case anything goes wrong
that's the most nervous I've ever been
how do the physical traits of the
character inform the performance in the
film if you if you want something
destroyed in a China show in the corner
of a china shop you let loose a bull in
there who are 100 percent sure that
things will be destroyed
that's what Auguste Walker is if you
were to fire a dart through the china
shop to hit one plate you're not
necessarily I'm so sure it's gonna work
right
it's always like a high-tension moment
that's an Ethan Hunt kind of thing and
that's what always prides himself on so
in this movie you play real heavyweight
very intimidating his team would be dead
yes they would
that's the job you ever shipped gears
into that in real life like if you're
ever in like a bad customer service type
situation very rarely I think but maybe
I'm mistaken maybe I think I'm nicer
than knowing that you're gonna play this
type of aggressive character the hammer
the bull does that affect your mindset
outside of the film no no it doesn't the
only thing that really affect my mindset
was obviously when I was shooting I had
a moustache and so it was very you
forget you forget a lot of the time and
I had to keep her in mind like I look at
Mary like oh yeah I forget I have a
moustache so easy to forget that you
have unless that's easy so easy stop
massage yes we know a lot about Tom
Cruise that yeah he's famously very nice
have you gleaned anything that really
bad bad we don't know yeah he does chop
his salad really small oh but he said I
guess I can get quicker and eat and walk
at the same time WW TD what would Tom do
as an actor how important is it for you
to change your appearance from film to
film I don't want to be the guy who
relies on tricks as always there's a
different appearance I want a bit of
both I think an appearance is very very
useful and I do like to chameleon myself
into another character in the same way
that theater actors do that is a real
art as well and so I want to utilize
that at the same time as utilizing all
the wonderful tricks of of film and
having having these different looks
every time makes total sense so let's
say you could get one of those IMF masks
yeah and you could impersonate anyone
who would it be I disguise myself as
Edgar right and go on set of a film one
day and give everybody a big kiss so the
next day he'd be the subject of the
universe
there you go get him in a little trouble
oh by the way there's something about
you that's giving off a little bit of a
Clark Kent vibe right now oh really yeah
I don't know what it is I think it's
because I shaved my moustache makes
sense why variant mousse well that was a
good time mission impossible fallout
opens in theaters everywhere this week
go see it it is non-stop action big
thanks to the cast and to mr. Henry
Cavill rings such a good sport I'm Hal
Rudnick hit me up on Twitter and
Instagram thanks for watching
bye bye
[Music]
[Laughter]